look amazing has always thank you for
being here and congratulations you got
engaged and a wedding plans you have big
big ideas I have big ideas I just nailed
down today that we're gonna do karaoke
band at the reception which is sort of
sad to kind of want to perform at your
own wedding oh so you're gonna actually
perform at the wedding I have seen I've
seen Brides do that before no it's not
sad really it's that no I'm curious
about you you you you're such a natural
performer and as you know I'm a big fan
of yours you see you're so naturally
funny were you were you a dramatic kid
were you someone who was a performer
even as a child I was very dramatic and
a lot of journaling a lot of intense
feelings always journaling about
friendships you know with girls like
every second if they're changing and
what you know rating them and that I
don't think they like me I don't think
the teacher likes me nobody likes me and
I ever draw guns that's really not good
I'm thinking out loud I'm like I needed
help yeah you should see a therapist so
you can say this out loud more often so
you you would journal here just do a lot
more talk show yeah yeah yeah so so you
would journal everything you had you
have you kept any of the journal I have
I brought just one one sheet I did a
feelings chart on I'm January 9th 1990
okay just the kind of document where all
my emotions were over the course of the
day and they go a lot of places can we
do this is if you actually have your
chart right here here are some views
this is one day's worth of feelings
I'm seeing Airy ears Airy yeah and then
there's another one unclean I thought
that area an area but one come you felt
unclean yeah it's sad that I guess a
child I would know at that moment that I
felt unclean but it was a feeling you
know and I I feel it right now is lost
that's this show the environment